[Music]
Rhianna working it on the September
cover of British Vogue and get this she
is the first black woman to appear on a
September cover of the mag ever you know
how I feel about inclusivity is so
important to me inside you get candid
about body image and has the best
response when asked why she thinks she's
the woman other women love quote maybe
it's because I'm
[Music]
thirty-year-old is joking but says she's
about to get back into a gym routine
adding I hope I don't lose my butt or my
hips or all of my thighs olives thumbs
but not all in dad's butt you know it
comes with a price you want to have a
butt then you have a gut all women
deserve to feel beautiful
Rhea has always been candid about beauty
and body with ET I'm very realistic when
I look in the mirror like I know if I'm
in shape out of shape if I got zits
about dark circle I'm not like lying to
myself and I'm not feeling bad about
that either it is what it is you forgot
there's dark circles I just wear more
makeup
[Music]